I've traveled all over Africa I've been
in rural Africa I've been everywhere I
can always find a coke and I can always
find a Fanta orange so why can't I
always find the vaccine that I need or
an oral rehydration solution for a child
that's having diarrhea don't choose a
very remote place and damn beer
somewhere near the Mozambique border for
example and wait and see whether the
vaccines show up sometimes they do but
that's not good in a visit they have to
reach all the health posts all the time
because of the nature of disease you get
an outbreak and the outbreak spreads
so when you ask the question about you
know what are the differences in
delivering vaccines and in a high
resource versus low resource country one
absolutely relates to costs and
financing the second major barrier is I
take my children to get vaccines I drive
a mile or two to the pediatricians
office I do that at my convenience and
my child gets those vaccines you don't
need many other places we're talking
about communities where they certainly
don't have cars in many instances they
may not have roads they don't have
pediatricians offices that you know are
available eight hours a day six days a
week so there are just logistical
transportation delivery barriers that
are quite different in those countries
than in in our country here
we know that the neglect of vehicles has
a profound effect on the health of
people across the continent so we
trained mechanics local mechanics to a
very high standard it's not just
maintaining vehicles but it's bringing
parts from wherever they are probably
Japan and also managing stores managing
the the parts and managing the people
managing the fuel so it sounds obvious
but what it is is actually quite
difficult to put on the ground but
without it nobody's going anywhere if
you're organizing a clinic and you're
inviting people to come to an outreach
station it's going to have to be the
third Thursday of every month and if
you're not there because your vehicle
breaks down lots of very disappointed
women who have walked 10 15 kilometres
with their babies are going to go away
but fewer of them will return so
predictability is absolutely essential
if you say it's the third Thursday you'd
better be there and it's no good saying
well my motorcycle broke down on my
pickup broke down because there's no
women there to hear you say it they've
gone by then and if you don't do that
in an orderly way you will never get
control of child immunization never
it's not reaching one person once with
something is reaching all the people all
the time is the problem and very few
people picture that children keep
getting born you know good monster don't
say oh that's enough children now I mean
they're born every day every hour you
have to reach all the new ones all the
time and you can't you can't mess about
with oil filters you have to change them
it's not optional
so in our program in The Gambia for
example we ran the first ten million
kilometres that's a lot of kilometres
with no breakdowns 100 percent of the
children born in that country are
immunized against everything because
they all got reached all the time
however wonderful your drug is however
good your vaccine is you cannot immunize
a child with a mobile phone you've got
to have a person see that child and all
the children in their area and you've
got to do it predictably and reliably so
I think that has to be a lesson that not
just we have learned but everybody needs
to think about
you